[Music]
your work
to do with scientific facts and the
strong program
could you explain what is a scientific
fact
no that's the whole argument
if there are any which i doubt um
then verbal explanation always fails to
capture
the whole of them so they change over
time because there's this wiggle room
between
what words say and what you can take
them to mean and over time that little
bit of wiggle room
can become very large
um so if you look at
as i have at facts over a long lifetime
in two different areas they both go the
same way
um science
produces things people that
reckon to be facts i reckon the
half-life is
a few years which is you know it's not
bad compared with
say a trump tweet which is a creature of
the day
and um big contrast
but uh if you re think the facts as
eternal verities or anything like that
no
they don't does that mean though that
they have if they have a half-life
they are facts for a certain amount of
time
some collective or other takes them that
way
for that time um
what you mean by uh
facts in an absolute sense is beyond me
i mean a platonist would have to be
interviewed to tell them
tell you or a mathematician
who lives in numberland somewhere
but if you do it from the point of view
of an empirical science
um there's
there's no satisfactory answer
is there still a sort of meaning behind
any scientific endeavor then yes
and what are we aiming for then into
subjective agreement
and what is it an inter-subjective
agreement it's where
people who have to get along with each
other bang around and meet each other
um agree to call these things facts
um or used to agree to call these things
facts i'm sure they do anymore actually
but
uh agreed to call these things facts
yeah and that's
an uh that's the usual way
people think about it there is another
way you can think of them as
the things in the world that make what
you believe about the world
factual beliefs or factually beliefs
beliefs
but
that's probably the minority vision
these days although it used to be very
important when science was
professionalizing
um and
of course these days i mean ask yourself
this if you work with a model
you're not working with any facts are
you or else it wouldn't be a model would
it
and loads people do these days right
from physics through to
biology you name it
people use models uh
so that's would you be able to expand on
that what does it why do you think that
working from a model
you're not working from facts in any way
well because um
how do you know the model is a model of
something
and if you haven't got access to the
something then it could turn out to be
quite wrong at any minute
um and people recognize anyway that
you know that the model boat whizzing
around on the lake
isn't a model of what a very tears ever
any more than the
model of the racing car that kids like
to use is a model
um so and then you know there's
same with theory you know the detective
stories
the detective has a theory and
um it
you give up the idea of a theory at the
end
and say you know you've got the culprit
there is the fact of the matter
the theory in a model are really very
closely related things
um and you can see that in
the sciences you know talk of models and
talk of theories very
overlaps massively um
and we always if we expect a fact we
expect something at the end of the
detective story
we've got to remember that's fiction so
um so that's where we're at so is there
any way
of saying that a theory or model is
better than
one or the other well people do do that
um people argue about that
i think you've got a session on the
higgs boson in the
festival um
and people are getting worried because
the higgs boson isn't behaving
itself so you
um other other theories are saying we
perhaps ought to go in another direction
at this point and they're having a
lovely argument
uh about what the status of this boson
is
in seven circles yeah
and it's just the same in biology i
know people study you via a rat model
what do you make of that
do you think you're just like the model
you see so what causes them the
half-life in which they sort of die out
different theories and models or facts
from these
well it's partly accidental i mean you
don't know any advance if you
think you've got discovers something and
then you say you've got a fact about
it or you know whatever you say
you don't know in advance how long it's
going to last
as a matter of shared agreement um
a lot of it's luck um
you know that the guy who
observed the satellites of uranus
identified seven of them
and there's only three of them left the
others have been
discarded as artifacts or accidents of
some sort or
errors of observation or whatever and
that's
you know i mean that's quite a vivid
example it's easy to understand but in
the levels of
fantasy theory it's just the same
so perhaps some of them will
last so long you know that after a bit
we'll call them the truth or whatever
um it's probably just at that point that
they'll die out that's what happened
with classical physics it was just when
it decided it was complete
and a work of beauty and genius that it
completely collapsed
so who knows
you never know and you talked about
before the fact that language
could never there was always error in
language in describing the world
does that mean that you think that uh
language itself can't be relied on to
describe the world and that
there still is an object of reality we
just can't describe it with language or
do you just think there is no
objective reality in which there is to
describe my personal view would be quite
close to what you've just said
i i think there's something out there it
might be
you know i mean there are people around
who are saying it's the whole world's an
illusion
so uh how do i show they're wrong
because if we're all deluded nobody's
got the standing to show illusion
exists anywhere um but
my personal habits incline me to think
there's something out there and when i
open my eyes in the morning i get in
contact with it
um but the problem there is as you say
there's a problem talking about it
or even pointing to it you know i i
talk about a bit of the world and
there's always something um
like a kind of lack of fit although it's
not really a lack of fit because you
don't know the really
except through the
either the model or whatever same way if
you point to something
no i i point to you how do you know i'm
not pointing at the camera over there
or it's a bit of you right now how do
you know
how to follow the line of my crooked
finger
it's indefinite and that's the direct
observation of fact
wobbling around it's indefinite so if
everything's indefinite
um that little bit of wobbling around
can get very much worse
over time there's more and more people
use the words
um and at some point it goes pop
people think this starts somewhere else
could you argue though that over time it
leads to more precision
rather than it leads to it
a theory or a model or a fact
you were saying that over time well
definitely what it does is get people
together
and as they get together and share
by agreeing that that matter of fact
and therefore they you're not allowed to
change them for a bit
if it were um you get them to interact
and shared knowledge grows a much more
rapid rate
than um fantasy knowledge or whatever
individual knowledge which is a
contradiction in terms
um so it does it is helpful
but the it's rather like driving on the
left helps
you live longer so forth
and i'm all for this sort of stuff and
i'm
part of uh part of communities where i
quite happily talk about what's out
there and
work in agreement with them and they
tell me things and i go
dude you found that out you know i'm
happy with that
a lot of people seem to be incapable of
being happy with things that
isn't going to last aren't going to last
forever
i suppose they think it's like death you
know you should be worried about it
but um it doesn't worry me
and is that quite a political process
though the means by which some things
get taken to be
fact or agreements and
do you think that there should be sort
of a more equal process by which
agreements or facts are made well the
process has changed from
one community to another
so you've got to judge it a collective
at a time
some collectives are far more
egalitarian and some are
extraordinarily hierarchical
traditionally science of course has
tried to operate like a group of peers
and that was not a bad idea at the time
in 2017 a hedge fund manager financed a
massive
experiment to see whether gravity waves
existed
and the whole scientific collective got
to work
around that and they figure they've
shown that gravity waves exist now
so high finances in there big time at
the moment
um and so where is this work taking you
recently
what sort of research or where are you
is your focus at the moment
um well my career
stopped a little time ago
um and it's a kind of
come full circle you'll see i'm doing
two singing me bobs
when i started my career i um i got
i got a job looking at the natural
scientists and i used a lot of work from
anthropologists and philosophers and
whatever
to try and make sense of what was going
on in
science and the science i was
particularly interested in at that time
for purely
accidental reasons was genetics
and people wandering around saying how
wonderful mendalism was and the truth
had been discovered and this and that on
the other
and um very end of my career
i helped in direction of the work of a
genomic center looking at the
sociology of the genomics if you like
and if you read a genomics textbook
today and realize it's
the inheritance of the science they
looked at
uh 40 more than 40 years ago
you see there aren't many facts left or
at least if there are any left they're
in chapter 28 instead of in chapter
21 and the field has changed out of all
recognition
and um you know somebody like me
you can't help but think there's a
half-life to be identified there
and um but that's why i
i've
done work in two areas because the work
on sex was the
stuff that came around full circle they
ended
but the work on facts
was to do with doing an awful lot of
work on science before
and then deciding what i've learned a
lot about
it you know i'm like an anthropologist
with a tribe
and i thought to myself well at this
point i'll pay the debt back and try and
use
the science to explain other things
going on
in the social sciences and um
and even in arts areas and
so i had a big swing of career from
facts
if you want to put it that way um to
um
or lack of facts uh
in science to looking at
sociology how it understood the world
and how the tribes
that it was studying looked at the world
and i was doing general sociology for
about a decade or so
and then i went back to doing the
research direction of the genomics
center again
so i've got these two strings
to talk about and i've got so many years
behind me you know plenty of years on
both of them so
i i can hope to tell people interesting
things about both
just conceivably we'll see whether i can
do that i don't know
so does that mean that you don't think
genomics has much to offer
economics genomics oh genomics oh i
think genomics loads to offer and i
think we know
an immense we've got a much more
sophisticated view of
genetics than the old classical genetics
had not their fault of course they
hadn't got the technology
but with the developments over the years
genetics has been transformed
and if if you go through it very slowly
it doesn't necessarily feel like it
every five minutes
but again it's these little wobbles in
meaning all add up over time and then
you get sudden shifts in the strata
you know like you get an earthquake
after a lot of pressure underground
and then lot of toddling along again a
bit of a shift again
you look at that of 40 years it's quite
amazing where you've got to
and uh same thing's happened in the
world of course the uh
everybody talks about gender these days
it's really very politically correct to
talk about
most things as sex
[Music]
so and you've done some work on
identifying the number of sexes that you
think could exist
this is true well
um what this way
uh i i've given it a lot of thought
yes do you have an answer i'm sorry do
you have an answer
to how many sexes how many sexes there
are i mean
do you fancy you think there could be an
endless amount of numbers
well i think with current knowledge we
could do quite a good job of knocking up
a few
if we wanted to um and
of course you've also got to remember
there are two ends to which you can
change things
we could probably knock up a few more by
using modern biotechnology
um in fact they have
um you know all the stuff about um
three parents these days um
you imagine biotechnology continuing to
chug away
with that but that of course is is
developed now there are examples where
the genetic parents of a child can be
identified as three or three if you
if you're in mind to do that and
think of um the more routine bits of dna
as coming from the third parent
but then it's up to us isn't it
it's it's um the world wasn't
one thing the world doesn't do is speak
of us
speak to us in any language at all
it can't speak to us it just sits there
and waits for us to notice things about
it
and to develop technologies and we
we actually steal the world's
ourselves to make technologies out of i
mean particularly in
biology these days viruses are now
technologies
in genomics and that their delivery
systems for genetic
information you want to stick into an
organism somewhere
and they do wonderful things with
viruses
having killed us off with millennia
they're now helping us along
so so you've got to bring bear in mind
the future
is very bound up with it with technology
and um and that's
partly us and partly out there if you
want to put it that way
i don't know what the answer is in words
uh sorry i'm very bad on results no
lovely i mean words aren't that reliable
as we've learned
uh they're not that's right thank you
very much
thank you
podcasts talks debates courses and
articles
visit the institute of art and ideas
click the link on screen now
to iai dot tv